[Música]
bienvenidos a este especial de deportes
en francés 24
la muerte de diego armando maradona
sacudió al mundo el 25 de noviembre de
2020 cerca del mediodía el astro
argentino de 60 años falleció como
consecuencia de un paro
cardiorrespiratorio icono del fútbol
mundial símbolo de la sociedad argentina
decenas de miles de personas asistieron
al velorio público en la casa rosada- en
la casa de gobierno antes de su entierro
en un cementerio privado ubicado al
noroeste de la capital buenos aires-
pero el recuerdo de maradona no fue sólo
de los argentinos sino también a nivel
global
para mí no está ahí está en mi corazón
diego nuestro oído lo hizo tan felices
fuimos felices con él fuimos felices y
rn muerto solo no sólo murió él murió
toda la ciudad de nápoles junto con
argentina no hay palabras no había
llorado desde la muerte de mi madre hace
dos años y después de ella solo diego me
hizo llorar
para nosotros era inmortal como un
superhéroe
antes de entender el fútbol entendía a
maradona porque la magnitud que tenía
era algo inigualable
él era un gran jugador de fútbol al
pueblo chino le gusta mucho y mucha
gente lo admira era un gran atleta
formosa formal es algo que duele porque
para mí maradona es como un dios del
fútbol cuando lo ves jugar hasta tú
tienes ganas de jugar es el jugador más
manera la historia no podemos decir otra
cosa podemos compararlo con otros pero
maradona es otra cosa es un genio
dentro del campo de juego maradona marcó
a generaciones y es considerado por
muchos el mejor jugador de fútbol de la
historia forjado en los potreros de
villa fiorito fue un talento precoz que
cumplió su sueño al ganar el mundial de
1986 con la selección argentina formado
en argentinos sueños amado en boca y el
nápoli recordado en barcelona sevilla en
you girls repasamos la carrera del 10
diego armando maradona el pibe de oro'
forjó su talento en los potreros de
villa fiorito e íntegro el equipo de los
cebollitas la clase 60 que rompió
récords en el fútbol infantil en 1976
diez días antes de cumplir 16 años
debutó como profesional en argentinos
juniors club que lo formó y lo catapultó
el mundial sub-20 de japón en 1979
maradona guió a la selección argentina a
su primer título juvenil 'el pelusa'
saltó al club de sus amores boca juniors
en 1981 un paso breve marcado por la
conquista del campeonato metropolitano
la primera experiencia europea llegó en
1982 con barcelona lejos de cumplir las
expectativas su paso por el club
blaugrana estuvo marcado por lesiones
polémicas y sólo tres títulos de copas
nacionales nápoles lo recibió con los
brazos abiertos y allí se coronó dios
con un equipo modesto del sur pobre de
italia acostumbrado a estar a la sombra
del norte rico maradona llevó al napoli
a ganar dos veces la serie una copa
italia una supercopa de italia y una
copa de la uefa entre 1984
992 una gloria que fue paralela a su
sueño cumplido el mundial con argentina
en los cuartos de méxico-86 firmó la
mano de dios' y se convirtió en
barrilete cómicos para sellar el mejor
gol de la historia de los mundiales ante
inglaterra una revancha futbolística
cuatro años después de la guerra de
malvinas
en el estadio azteca como capitán al
suelo trofeo más deseado y estuvo cerca
de repetirlo en 1990 pero alemania con
un polémico penal se llevó la final en
italia en marzo del 91 dio positivo por
primera vez en un control antidopaje y
cumplió 15 meses de suspensión regresó
con pasos fugaces por sevilla y ni un
sol boix
a finales de 1993 volvió a la selección
para el repechaje de eeuu 94 ante
australia
ese equipo logró la clasificación e
ilusionó con el mundial pero a maradona
le cortaron las piernas al dar positivo
por efedrina y derivados
tras otros 15 meses de suspensión
retorno la boca para cerrar su carrera
siempre ligado al fútbol busco ser
entrenador aunque con pocas
posibilidades grandes con antecedentes
en mandiyú y racing club tuvo su gran
oportunidad en la selección tras una
tortuosa eliminatoria la derrota por
goleada ante alemania en los cuartos de
sudáfrica-2010 selló su suerte al wsell
y al fujairah en emiratos árabes unidos-
dorados de sinaloa y gimnasia de la
plata completaron su rol en los
banquillos con problemas de salud era
director técnico del lobo al momento de
su muerte la que los sorprendió en
soledad y no cerca del césped ese que
siempre lo hizo feliz
como futbolista maradona generó
admiración casi unánime fuera de la
cancha se convirtió en una figura de
culto en un ídolo popular pero también
en un personaje controvertido por su
relación con las drogas y episodios de
violencia
luís muñoz se explica los claroscuros
del astro argentino
diego armando maradona amado y odiado
una figura que trascendió al fútbol
tanto que debe ser de los pocos humanos
con su propia religión la iglesia
maradoniana más allá de sus tantos
maradona fue considerado dios una figura
tan grande que terminó consumida por su
propia sombra tuvo polémicas dentro del
campo como la mano de dios en los
cuartos de final del mundial de méxico
de 1986 contra inglaterra un gol con la
mano que él mismo denominó como la
venganza por las islas malvinas también
en el terreno de juego en su época en el
barcelona dio la vuelta al mundo su
agresión a dos futbolistas del athletic
club de bilbao un suceso que le costó un
castigo de tres meses de sanción
pero más allá del campo en barcelona
también empezó su etapa más oscura allí
comenzó a consumir drogas las cuales
marcaron su carrera él mismo dijo que
esta adicción dio ventajas al resto de
futbolistas en 1991 el mundo del fútbol
quedó conmocionado por su positivo por
cocaína un dopaje que se repetiría en
1994 antes del mundial en esta ocasión
por efedrina en ese momento cansado del
acoso de parte de la prensa el jugador
sacó un rifle de
comprimido y disparo a los periodistas
la adicción le llevó al borde de la
muerte en 2000 y 2004 pero el personaje
va más allá de sus adicciones en 2014 su
pareja en ese momento rocío oliva
difundió un vídeo en el que se veía a
diego armando en estado de ebriedad
golpeando la polémica donde tampoco
faltó a la política
maradona nunca olvidó sus orígenes
siempre recordó el hambre que pasaba a
su madre para alimentarles unas
vivencias que le llevaron a un gran
compromiso político forjando amistad con
personajes como fidel castro o hugo
chávez además de lucir siempre el
tatuaje del che guevara 60 intensos años
de maradona carismáticos muchas veces
polémicos muchas otras y como él siempre
dijo no es fácil ser maradona
las virtudes defectos y contradicciones
de maradona representan para muchos
argentinos una muestra de la identidad
nacional de su país la historia de amor
de maradona y argentina inició en villa
fiorito el 30 de octubre de 1960 tuvo
sus primeros brillos en argentinos
juniors y se llenó de pasión en boca
juniors un equipo de france 24 de sando
los primeros pasos del 10 en el fútbol
argentino
la historia de amor de diego maradona
con argentina comenzó aquí en villa
fiorito uno de los suburbios más
modestos de buenos aires en esta casa
nació el pibe de oro' su amigo de la
infancia
norberto recuerda a un niño que sólo
quería jugar al fútbol y era su sueño
[Música]
llegará a ser profesional no esto que
luego hacer el periodo jugar
profesionalmente como cualquier jugador
y poder ayudar a su familia
un sueño que se hizo realidad de núcleo
cuyo estadio ahora lleva su nombre
argentinos juniors diez días antes de
cumplir 16 años
maradona inició su carrera profesional
consiguiendo un contrato y casa para él
y su familia
la fama de diego trasciende el fútbol se
grabó en los corazones de las personas
porque podían relacionarse con él con
motivos de orgullo y aspiración para
muchos aficionados devastados por su
muerte el gear pero riego no se va a
morir nunca porque el que ama nunca
olvida acá en nápoles en todo el mundo
porque el donde estuvo dejó su su
granito de arena
quiero
maradona consolidó su nombre en la
cultura popular argentina reveló su pase
al legendario club boca juniors en 1981
durante una ilustre temporada en la
bombonera maradona bailó a los
defensores rivales ganando el campeonato
nacional convoca los fanáticos no lo
olvidan
diego es único es único a nivel mundial
y por eso quisimos rendirle este
homenaje para que lo disfrute todo el
pueblo de boca maradona saltaría
posteriormente a europa donde se
convirtió en una leyenda pero su corazón
estaría para siempre en la argentina
el vínculo de diego con su país vivió
hasta su último aliento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
si hay un lugar que puede equipararse
con argentina por la admiración a
maradona
ese es nápoles de identificación de la
ciudad con el astro argentino es total y
sobrepasa lo futbolístico por eso tras
su muerte el alcalde de la ciudad luis
de magistris dispuso el cambio del
nombre del estadio san paolo por el de
diego armando maradona también fue
renombrada en la estación de metro de la
línea 6 que ahora será mostra a maradona
y tendrá una exposición dedicada al
napoli y al 10
en esa ciudad un discreto local alberga
desde hace 14 años una magnífica
conexión de cientos de objetos
vinculados al dios futbolístico de la
ciudad nuestra periodista natalia ruiz
giraldo recorrió el lugar y nos cuenta
más
estamos en un barrio popular al norte de
nápoles en donde se encuentra uno de los
tesoros más grandes que pueda tener esta
ciudad pero para llegar aquí hay que
hablar con los locales porque no está en
ningún mapa aquí dentro de este sótano
se encuentra un verdadero santuario
hecho para diego armando maradona hay
cientos miles de objetos que
pertenecieron a la 10 cuando jugaba con
él a nápoles aquí en esta ciudad
italiana es de verdad un lugar perfecto
un paraíso para los amantes del fútbol y
sobre todo de maradona pues se dedica
también este es un museo dedicado a mi
padre y diego porque tuve la suerte de
que mi padre fuera durante 35 años el
encargado del estadio de san paolo y
sobre todo de los vestuarios mi madre
era la cocinera y ama de llaves de la
casa maradona y mi hermana la niñera de
dalma y de giannina son todos los
recuerdos que le regaló a toda mi
familia
de los miles de objetos que hay aquí
quizás este es uno de los más
representativos de esta chaqueta que
seguramente ustedes reconocen que
utilizó el astro argentino cuando
calentaba para la final de la copa de la
uefa en 1989 copa que ganó con el napoli
todo el paso de diego armando maradona
durante los siete años que estuvo aquí
en nápoles todo eso se puede
prácticamente vivir aquí
diego era diego era un campeón aún más
grande fuera de la cancha que dentro de
ella una persona generosa con un corazón
grande y humilde así nació porque el
riego no está muerto diego vive su
cuerpo no está pero su espíritu
permanezco por alan y me descentre ido
este lugar se puede visitar en
gratuitamente pero se invita a dejar una
donación porque todas estas donaciones
serán dadas a los niños desfavorecidos
de nápoles por ahora máximo vignatti
pues se espera mantener este lugar
abierto pero él quisiera quizás en un
futuro que todo este museo pues se tenga
un lugar dedicado en el futuro estadio
diego armando maradona aquí en nápoles
muchas gracias por acompañarnos en este
programa especial sigan con más en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]
y boca
venid a cualquier lugar la vida es una
tómbola
de noche y de día